uh so hello everyone
um October 31 so probably if you think
about this date you will think about
pumpkins candies or costumes but October
31 is also our ladies anniversary so the
first ever our ladies event took place
on San Francisco on October 31 2012 so
this mean that last year was our L's
10th
iary happy
birthday so if you're here you probably
already know that our ladies is a
worldwide organization that promotes
gender diversity in the art community
via meetups and mentorships in a
friendly and safe environment but it
started small only eight people show up
to the first event it was
Halloween but today we have 231 chapters
in 63 cities and we have organized
almost 4,000
events so this means that the past 10
years have been years of growth and this
has been possible thanks to the work of
people organizing chapters around the
world and our ladies that engage in
social media in the slack community and
in the different initiatives that the
community organized and it has also been
possible thanks to the work of the
global team the people that help us to
maintain and develop our Technical and
social
infrastructure so our 10th year
anniversary was also a moment for fare
wealth Claudia Arin and Hannah Ste down
as organizers thank you they led us
through so they led us through 10 years
of growth so a new leadership was needed
and there's always people that fell into
this kind of task so these are the five
people who decide to engage with
this so we have Mo we have Avery Yanni
Shannon and me Riva and that is why
we're here today to talk about how we're
envisioning Our Ladies next 10 years and
what we're thinking here is about how to
sustain the community how we how our
efforts can work towards sustaining uh
the growth of this community so we are
people who love to code and we were
thinking in the last year what if we use
good programming practices to manage our
programming Community for example
modularity refactoring and testing so
what about modularity you don't want a
function that it's that big what you
want to do is to make it in small chunks
so it's flexible you can maintain it
easily and you can develop new features
so what about communities you want to do
the same but this is about workflow
workload obviously you don't want just
one person taking all the work but it
not it's not just about workload there
are other things involved for example if
you have a team that's working on the
website and they're only working on the
website they don't have to take care
about other tasks they can focus their
effort on uh feature development so
making your work your website cooler and
it's also important in terms of
participation because not everyone can
engage as an organizer or as part of the
global team in the same way not everyone
has the same time patterns to commit for
example you may have some volunteers
that have three hours a week that they
can devote only on Friday afternoon but
you have other people that prefer to
work on small uh tunks of time so they
can work maybe go to the computer two
times a day and work there around 10 and
20 minutes so if you have a um community
that can offer people different ways to
engage they can be part of the team and
help you uh and all your community with
the work and there are some task where
you need people that have these uh
timing patterns for example you want
someone moderating a community that
engage not just one day three hours but
that's there many many times a week this
is also important for the ways that
people can participate so sometimes you
want to participate in a community for
learning new things so if you want to
learn how to code more about coding you
might want to participate for example in
the website team but if you want to I
don't know uh engage um in things that
have to uh that are related to social
skills maybe you want to be part of the
mentoring tip of Our Ladies so this
gives space for everyone so one thing
that we are for sure going to uh keep
working towards is have a modular Global
team so this can uh help everyone to
participate in meaningful
ways so what about
refactoring sometimes we have code that
works and we want keep it that way we
don't want to touch it and the same
happen with projects so sometime you
have a project that you really love you
really care about the vision of of of
that project and you really don't care
the kind of work that involves to keep
the project alive life um and that's
because you have the vision of the
project in front of you so you're really
committed to that but it's good to think
about how we can refactor our workflows
as Community organizers to make everyone
participate in meaningful
ways so refactoring your growth flows is
not only about making your community
more efficient but it's also about
making the time that people are
committing as Volunteers in your
community more meaningful because you
don't want people committing time that
can be that's only about repetitive task
that can be automated you want them
doing relevant
things so as an example um we can
explain what what happened with the Our
Ladies directory so the Our Ladies
directory is an initiative that's very
related to our ladies mission that help
us showcasing what our ladies do around
the world and it's an excellent antidote
to allmade
panels so for example in the directory
you can learn about for example if you
want to engage someone in Botswana that
know about computer science there is
seei or if you want to engage and know
someone that's working in open
environmental science there's Julia or
you want to know people that are working
with our in ecology you can find
benedicta or people that are working in
Health Equity you can find Sylvia on the
directory so the directory this is how
the directory used to uh look on the web
page so to um add your entry to the
directory you can there's a form there
that you can use and there used to be
this message if you want to update your
profile just fill the same form and drop
us a line in the comment box saying you
want to update your profile and there
was this extra option or you can just
email us at speakers our.org with any
relevant information about yourself easy
yes easy because the project was
starting and what you wanted was people
sending their data so you can showcase
them in the directory but what happens
behind the scene with this workflow so
you have a spreadsheet and people start
submitting their entries and you have to
take this information and put it on the
website and you work in these two
entries so you're going to put a color
to remember that you those are already
on the website and you keep working and
then this one is not really well so
you're going to work in this one
afterwards so you put another color in
there so you remember that this one has
a problem and you keep working and then
you realize that it is this entry in the
comment they put this is an update so
you have to treat this one differently
and then an email arrives and you have
to take the information from the email
and put it here so it can goes to the
directory so this workflow worked so it
worked for years and it could have kid
working but it has some problems it's
difficult to maintain there there's a
lot of space for for human error so you
don't want someone submitting their data
and not you not uploading it to the
directory you can schedule the work so
maybe you decide that you want to work
on the directory on Fridays but you
receive an email on Monday on Tuesday on
Wednesday about people wanting to upload
their data and because you're only
working on maintaining the directory you
can think of future development so how
to enhance what we have there and this
is a test that has a high risk of
burnout
because you what the directory does is
really awesome so it helps showcase what
our ladies are doing around the world so
maybe you don't care that it's a
repetitive task copy and paste
information to the website but things
happen in life and sometimes under
certain circumstances you're not seeing
what the bigger picture is and you
realize that your only copy basing
information and don't understand why and
this is like a perfect the perfect
recipe for
Burnout so last year there was an
opportunity Mo was leading the team to
turn our website from WordPress to Hugo
and this one was an opportunity to think
again about the workflow that we have
for the directory to think in a way that
people can work in it and it's
meaningful and we can end with the same
result so we still have a form the form
is there people still um submit their
data through a
form but now we're working with their
table and we now people H choose an
option that's parametri side if it's a
new directory entry if this is an update
or they want to delete the entry and now
we're using GitHub actions so GitHub
actions are a way to automate the
workflow of taking the data from the
form and move it to the website so
basically in the directory Repository we
have a folder with our actions there's
the workflow there are a lot of work
workflows but one is about updating um
taking the data from our table and move
it to the website this a glimpse of um
the workflow but what's important here
is that it runs on
Friday so it's schedule so people know
in the team know when the data is going
to appear um in the repository so
basically what the workflow does is that
it takes a couple of uh our scripts that
get the data from our table that
validate the DAT on files and then the
action create a p request um gith have
actions allowed you to customize the
commit message the branch name the
labels that you want to add the title of
the um of your pool request and the
experience of the team at the end is
very different because in the previous
workflow this is what we they were
dealing with and now on Fridays Apple
request appears with all the data ready
to be committed to the
website so now the task the focus of the
task is on the review not in copy
pasting the task can be scheduled and
people have time for planning features
for the website for example how to
filter um the entries that are there on
some other awesome stuff that the
website and the director team are always
thinking
about so refactoring workflows is an
opportunity also for learning so we like
to solve problems using Code so
refactoring your work flows is not extra
work but it's work that probably people
in your community will want to be engag
with because they're going to learn
something new about programming so if
you want to be in next Friday's full
request you have to go to our l.org
directory Das update and your entry will
be be
updated so a way to discover that your
workflows need uh a little bit of
refactoring is testing your
workflows so we we always want to ensure
that our code behave as as expect as
expected so we want to do the same with
our workflows we want to our work our
worklow to behave as expected so I'm
going to tell a a little story I um
became part of the global team two years
ago as a slack uh mon a part of the
slack monitoring team um and this is a a
task that I jump into very easily
because I was already a person who was
using slack I was I know how the code of
conduct uh of Our Ladies work because I
was an organizer so it was very easy to
me to know how to perform this
task and a couple of months later there
were people needed for the Meetup uh
Team people who managed the Meetup
account of all all the chapters and I
fell I wasn't able to successfully start
doing this task and I was wondering why
because there's very good documentation
so there's all the the goal of the task
all things that a a Meetup account
manager needs to do was very well
explained but I didn't know how to
become the person that can use the
documentation so there was a gap between
me and the documentation that I didn't
experience when I was working in slack
because I already was Amar with that and
I discovered that the um the problem was
not with the technical infrastructure
but with the social infrastructure so
for example to use that documentation I
needed some credentials but I didn't
knew who I didn't know who I need to ask
for for that credentials and the person
who gave the credentials didn't know
that I was in need of
them so we were basically testing in
production and the problem of test this
is absolutely valid you can do this but
the problem the pro the problem of
testing production is that in some cases
what happened is something failed and in
this occasion with perspective I know
that what fail was the workshop the
workflow but at that moment I thought
that I was failing because I wasn't able
to complete the task that I was expected
to do so designing on boarding processes
can help you to test your community
workflows and documentation this is an
excellent way to realize that what your
the way that your workflows are working
is what you expect so this is very
important this is like time you want to
spend in so I'm a Serial
volunteer I very good at jumping into
volunteers positions and there's another
project that I participate in that's
called programming historian where we
publish uh tutorials about uh
computational tools for people in the
humanities and in this in this project
we have an onboarding process that's
basically opening an issue and saying
people how to engage uh with a project
we have very good
documentation so all the tasks that
people needs to know are there but what
we on board people because we need to we
need them to became the person that can
use the
recommendation so in this issue that we
open we welcome people because we're
nice um we explain what the project will
do uh what the programming team will do
to on board you we we explain people
what they should do to be on boarded
and that allow us to people um um get
becoming part of the team with no
problem so at our ladies we start
designing on boarding processes um this
is the first one we we Tred we try to
explicit mention the task it has three
hearts but this first version has a very
complicated problem we hardcoded things
we hardcoded people's names and you
never hard code people's names on your
documentation because for example last
week we discovered that Hannah was still
on
documentation and people were going to
ask her to create gab repositories and
we want Hannah working on Tidy models
not creating repositories for other
people so now we are improving our
onboarding processes and now we only
mention teams because it's it's easier
to
maintain so every time we board a new m
remember we discovered new ways to
improve our documentation H and our
workflows and we're going to keep
working on that so obviously we we ask
ourselves what if what if we automate
part of the process so now we have a
gith have action that uh we dispat we
dispatch it by running our workflow
manually and what we do is that we put
the team that the person is getting on
board the name of the person and their
gith have handle and when we run this
workflow what is going to happen like
very fast is that it will take our issue
template um it will um take the
information from the inputs that we put
there will we get the user ID check if
it's already on our organization invite
the user to the organization wait for
the user to accept the invitation add
the user to the corresponding G GitHub
team combine the templates and replace
placeholder and finally create an issue
to welcome someone new to the glob
so that's only you have to click some
buttons and the template is
there so as we said before we love
coding and in this past year we've been
thinking how we can use these good
programming practices to improve the
work that we're doing our our L Global
and the takeaways here is that designing
a mod Community is a good way to
distribute work and to distribute work
in a meaningful way refactor your
workflows is important to avoid
repetitive task and on the long run make
your process easier to maintain and
avoid burnout and creating on boarding
processes is a good way to test your
Technical and social
infrastructure uh to keep all your
processes run smoothly so let's bring
the joy of programming to our community
management and hope you can take some of
these ideas and putting on practices on
your own
communities thank
[Applause]
you
all right Raa in the last 30 seconds can
you say anything about how you're
handling knowledge transfer as you're
going through leadership transitions
that's a very good question so um a
couple of years ago um um the art
consumtion helped us to finance H
creating a our ladyes guide so we have a
knowledge base that is available for
everyone so the transition so in terms
of knowledge about the organization we
have the uh that that as a knowledge
base um and so I think the most
difficult things have been like
bureaucratic things that are involved in
an organization like that banks for
example Banks okay fantastic let's thank
Rea
[Applause]
again